[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and when I was born
the doctors told my parents they had a
cool son
the fourth episode of season seven is
finally here and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down whether
the de souza saviors or the Sousa losers
two incredibly bad puns they're back to
back now there's a lot to unpack from
the episode including some amazing
Easter eggs big moments and things that
hint out what's really going on in the
show throughout this video we're going
to be going through them all and also
discussing how the show might actually
link back in with the Avengers now
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't anything ruined
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now please drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video and make sure you
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
on the show week by week without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get to our breakdown of agents of shield
okay so the episode opens with the
Marvel logo changing to black and white
a motif that's used throughout the
episode after the EMP disable Coulson
last week his lmd tech is running a bit
haywire and thus we see things
throughout the episode - the bright
color palette that the show is known for
it really adds a film noir style to the
entry and the score accompanies this to
really give the episode a style of its
own that makes it stand out against the
most other entries in the series whether
it's the horns that play in the
background when certain reveals are made
the narration that tells the storyline
or even just the way things are shot
everything has the feeling of a film
noir police tragedy which is fitting for
the overall arc of the episode now we
open with Coulson and handcuffs who
after noticing the date on a newspaper
remembers that this is a very important
day in shield history as it's the day
that agent Sousa is killed according to
the history books Sousa would deliver a
groundbreaking device to how its stock
and then become the first fallen agent
of shield his murder was never solved
and the episode centers around saving
his life the day is also a very special
day for a number of reasons and on the
front page of the newspaper
see several headlines one says that
there are more subs planned which would
of course lead to the cold war and the
composer Duke Ellington is also playing
the first integrate casino which shows
that the race barriers are slowly
starting to lower arlington was a
composer throughout the early 20th
century however his career died off a
bit at the end of the 40's before he
received a big revival in the 1950s
which this concert likely helped start
now because of his knowledge of the past
Colson is able to convince Sousa that
he's actually in on the mission there's
also a line about the Kronecker melting
like the Wicked Witch of the East which
Colson then corrects to West I think
this actually might show the time
differences correctly as in The Wizard
of Oz book the Wicked Witch of the East
was also a big villain however she was
removed for the movie and it could show
that Colson is only aware of the film
adaptation
whereas Sousa is aware of them both due
to him actually being from the time that
it was released after mentioning stock a
twin Sue's around and the pair board a
train to LA and also get in touch with
Enoch who we see working at a shield
safehouse he's tending bar at the crazy
canoe and hey still bartending a turns
out Enoch
only did have one job a thumbs up uns
right there
now when the character was a left in the
past we did theorize that he would be
taking the long way around to meet them
again and though I had a feeling that
this was coming I was still really happy
to see him back they don't unite with
him as I expect but we'll talk about
this more towards the end of the video
he patches Coulson through to the Zephyr
with a switchboard and we see Jemma Mac
and Daisy I think Jem is standing there
completely discounts the Simmons as an
alum D theory now as if she was she
would have been taken out by the EMP -
it was a good theory I enjoyed reading
it but yeah I think now we know for
definite that she's not Deacon yo yo go
to dr. Lynn Moore's house aka Souza's
contact however here they find his body
with his face absorbed meaning that the
chronic comms have taken over his
identity after seeing this I do kind of
wonder if the chronic comms are only
taking the identity of people who would
also die on that day so that things
don't change too much and it could be
that the scientist was originally killed
around the same time as Sousa because of
what he knew there's a
hydro reveal in this episode and it does
kind of hint to me at least that the
chronic comes they only really go after
people and take their identity if they'd
be dead around the same time Hydra thugs
do show up to the house and this does
confirm that they were always meant to
be there but again it's a lot of time
you why me wibbly-wobbly stuff though
yo-yo gets the briefcase the thugs
kidnapped deke and they were unable to
me Coulson aboard the train through
Enoch yo-yo contacts the Zephyr and I
love how he knocks off just a switch
board throughout this entire episode I
actually think that this is a call back
to the original shield agents as they
used to do the same thing in agents of
Carter with Sousa getting suspicious
Coulson buys time and decides to take a
stranger's briefcase who he pretends as
his contact aboard the Zephyr they look
over the device which is revealed to be
the rosetta stone of shield tech it's
here that we get our first hint of
what's going on with May and similar to
Simmons she beams over it and we then
get confirmed that since crossing over
into isil's world and coming back her
emotions have been messed with she's
unable to experience things herself and
only gains emotions through touching
other people who mimicking of Simmons
shows this and explains why she had a
nervous breakdown in the previous
episode as at the same time the
scientists were trying to escape now we
don't know this for definite yet but it
does also kind of quash the may as I
sell theories for now obviously things
could change and they could be sharing a
body but for the moment it does seem
unlikely back on the train the lead
chronic calm who took the face of the
policeman in Episode one meets with
Coulson he tries to convince him to hand
over the earth in exchange for his kind
allowing humanity to have some luxuries
and I would have taken the deal Coulson
they caught a comp be any worse than
20/20 now he turns it down because he
doesn't trust the face taking race and
says that if they try anything
shield will meet them with the same
aggression the chronic comms don't seem
to care and they say they're changing
the timelines slightly and decide to
kill Sousa there and then rather than on
the night up top in the Train a pretty
woman tries to distract Sousa but he
quickly becomes aware that assassins are
closing in on him and he fights with the
group before being saved by Daisy and
Mack they take Suzy to the Zephyr who
obviously has some quest
djinns but he also states that he has a
theory that shield was infiltrated by
Hydra Malick who they left in 1931 had
indeed start of the group once more and
used it to infiltrate shield as
prophesized we come face to face with
Malick in the episode and learn that
under his orders Souza was taken out to
keep the secret quiet and now he doesn't
recognize dick initially it's clear that
that Deeks in a lot of trouble
Malick almost kills him but deke makes
him remember their shared history and
Malick lets him live saying that he owes
him a debt well that's good the ice is
still getting thin on Souza they have to
deliver the package and let him die in
order to keep the timeline intact
Coulson explains that Souza's sacrifice
was necessary as it inspired other
agents to risk their lives on missions
and this of course parallels Coulson's
own death in the Avengers which inspired
the heroes to come together for the
Battle of New York they do kind of get
the best of both worlds by the end of it
and through maze emotions they learn
that Sousa wants to run and he flees to
the Roosevelt Hotel Mack makes the
decision to send Coulson in instead and
he takes his place he's shot in the back
and then falls into the pool which leads
to him being the one left floating face
down
we don't really see this straight away
and actually did think that Sousa had
died for a second which they play with
the emotions sometimes in the show now
Simmons and yo-yo poses the coroner and
fish him out and because Sousa is
thought of as dead it means that the
timeline is intact
last time we theorized that this would
lead to a saw of mirror version of
Captain America and I loved the
similarities between the two cabins
Sousa of course loved Peggy but where
cap was taken out of time to go to the
future before going back to live with
her Sousa is taken out of time to go
with the agents of shield on their
mission now if you cast your mind back
to the Avengers movie you may remember
that the same actor that played Sousa
also plays a policeman in that it is
possible that they could slowly be
setting up that his leg gets fixed he
goes on missions with them and then is
dropped off in the 2000s to become a
policeman for the NYPD we don't know
this for definite yet but I hope it's
true as it would be a really cool way to
kind of just line everything up Coulson
gets his eye fixed and we finally get
some color in the show may touches
Coulson but gets not
and then the group decide to follow the
chronic calmness to the 70s we know this
for definite as it's confirmed by the
preview next week and also the song no
more mr. nice guy by Alice Cooper which
was released in 1973 also I do feel a
bit bad on Enoch I mean he was just left
for decades don't don't worry though may
I still love you Colson debrief Sousa
and though it looks like you will be
joining the agents it has been said that
he won't be a permanent member and
Vergil gotcha which I've definitely not
pronounced right told TV line not to get
our hopes up that he's gonna be around
forever but that he will be there for a
while so yeah the the Avengers thing
could definitely happen the post-credits
stinger ends with the chronic comm
leader going back to Malick and offering
to work with him for the future it is
possible that Malick actually agreed to
hand over humanity to the chronic comms
and this is why the tech like Zola's
algorithm was put in place in the Winter
Soldier perhaps they are the AI that
ends up running it and it could actually
be keeping the timeline intact just by
them being there that pretty much wraps
up the episode but as for next week
we're gonna be talking about the preview
of that so if you don't want to know
anything then duck out now yeah so the
group are indeed going to the 70s and it
looks like they're actually meeting with
general stoner who you may remember left
a message for the shield members at the
lighthouse it was quite an apocalyptic
message that seemed to prophesize the
future and a lot of people including
myself just didn't know what the hell
was going on with it now it is possible
at next episode they actually set up
that message being recorded as he did
seem to be aware of things that he
really shouldn't have been this would
explain how he was able to do it and
yeah it's nice that the kind of closing
all of the gaps and cutting off the
loose ends as as I think this shows
really starting to come together now
Enoch also does the amazing line come
with me if you want to continue to exist
which is of course a nod to the
terminator this was set in the 80s but I
I'll forgive them if it means we get
Enoch back anyway that ends the episode
completely and it was another great
entry in the show I love this format
they're doing so far and I think that
this season has been absolutely smashing
it now obviously I loved hear your
thoughts on the fourth episode so make
sure you comment below
and let me know if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a thumbs up and
if you missed our analysis of any of the
other episodes so that make sure you
check them out after this you want to
support the child from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and I said
thank you you get access to content
early you only come chat to us after the
show either follow us that heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this Monty
Cohn the MCU and finicky saga boxer and
all you have to do is comment on a video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of June and
the cell be shipped out from then Tova
gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part yes
[Music]